Nos piden graficar la función "f" de "x" igual a raíz cuadrada de "0.5x" menos 1.
Muy bien, la idea es que vamos a tomar una muestra
de valores de "x" que estén en el dominio de la función.
Vamos a evaluar la función en estos valores
y con eso vamos a obtener algunos puntos de la gráfica
que después vamos a conectar,
para darnos una idea de cómo está la gráfica, vale.
Bueno, entonces déjame poner por aquí una tabla
y en esta tabla lo que vamos a hacer...
lo que vamos a hacer,
es calcular la función en algunos valores de "x".
Si te das cuenta estoy poniendo tres columnas,
ahorita te digo porque,
en la primera columna voy a poner "x"
y en la última voy a poner "f" de "x", vale
Ahora, la idea va a ser la siguiente,
aquí tenemos que sacar raíz cuadrada de "0.5x"
y eso usualmente es complicado,
sacar raíces sin una calculadora es muy difícil,
si tenemos raíz de 7, va a estar feo.
Entonces la idea, es que vamos a intentar hacer
que raíz de "0.5x" sea un número entero,
es decir, vamos a intentar que "0.5x"
sea un número cuadrado.
Entonces pues déjame poner por aquí "0.5x"...
"0.5x"...
y la idea es que vamos a obtener los valores de "x",
los valores muestra,
pensando en que queremos que "0.5x"
sea un número cuadrado, un cuadrado perfecto, vale-
Entonces déjame ponerle por aquí
que queremos que sea un cuadrado perfecto.
Entonces,
¿qué números pueden ser cuadrados perfectos?
pues el 0 por ejemplo, el 0 es cuadrado perfecto
¿va?
entonces déjame poner por aquí el 0.
El 1 también es cuadrado perfecto,
el 2 y el 3 no,
porque ningún número al cuadrado da ni 2 ni 3,
entonces aquí tendría que seguir con el 4.
¿va?
luego vamos a obtener valores de "x"
en realidad podríamos probar
cualquier valor que quisiéramos de "x"
pero otra vez, la idea es que queremos
que la cuenta no salga facilita
ahorita vas a ver a qué me refiero.
Déjame seguir con algunos otros cuantos cuadrados,
el siguiente cuadrado es 9,
el siguiente cuadrado es 16,
y finalmente voy a poner el 25, vale.
Bueno, ahí tenemos 6 valores para "0.5x"
pero lo que nosotros necesitamos son valores de "x".
Entonces, cómo le hacemos para obtener
el valor de x conociendo  "0.5x".
Pues resolvemos una ecuación, por ejemplo,
la primera nos dice que es "0.5x"
es igual a 0.
Sí, eso es lo que nos dice esta entrada,
entonces si "0.5x" es igual a 0
"x" es igual a...
dividimos entre 0.5, entre ambos lados,
nos queda que "x"
es igual a 0 entre 0.5 que es 0,
entonces aquí sería "x" igual a 0
¿va?
Pero ve, lo único que hicimos fue dividir entre 0.5
y eso es lo mismo que multiplicar por 2,
déjame poner en otro color esto,
para que sea un poco más claro...
¿Va? entonces,
si queremos obtener ahora el valor de "x" aquí,
tenemos que dividir 1 entre 0.5
pero dividir entre 0.5
es lo mismo que multiplicar por 2,
así que "x" nos queda 2,
y de manera similar aquí "x" nos queda 8,
acá nos queda 18,
de este lado nos queda 32
y finalmente,
el último valor es "x" igual a 50, va.
Entonces estos valores de "x"
nos garantizan obtener estos valores de "0.5x"
y a partir de eso,
ya va a ser muy fácil calcular "f" de "x".
Vamos a hacer las cuentitas,
para ver cuánto nos queda, vale.
Entonces pensemos que "x" es igual a 0
y vamos a calcular "f" de "x".
Entonces si "x" es igual a 0
"f" de "x" es raíz, usando la definición,
es raíz de 0.5
0.5 por 0
y luego a eso tenemos que restarle 1.
0.5 por 0, es 0
menos 1 es igual a -1,
raíz de 0 es 0, 0 menos -1 es -1.
Muy bien,
ahora vamos con el segundo valor
aquí tenemos que hacer
raíz de 0.5 por "x",
"x" es 2, entonces es 0.5 por 2
y a eso tenemos que restarle 1.
0.5 por 2,
pues justo lo tenemos aquí verdad, es 1,
entonces nos queda 0.5 por 2 que es 1,
raíz de 1 es 1 menos 1, nos queda igual a 0.
Muy bien, déjame continuar
para que veamos cómo va esta cosa,
ahora vamos a tener raíz de 0.5
por
8, verdad,
"x" es igual a 8
pero justo hicimos las cosas,
para que esta raíz nos quedara raíz de 4,
entonces raíz de 4 es 2
y tenemos que restar 1
esto nos queda igual a 2...
eh... perdón 2 menos 1 es 1,
nos queda igual a 1.
Entonces ya se ve el patrón,
como que estamos sumando 1, verdad,
déjame continuar
con los otros valores
ahora tenemos que hacer raíz de...
raíz de 0.5 por 18
0.5 por 18 es 9,
raíz de 9 es 3
y 3 menos 1 es igual a 2.
Muy bien, ya nada más nos faltan dos valores
aquí es raíz de 0.5 por 32
menos 1,
nos queda, raíz de 16 menos 1,
o sea, 4 menos 1 que es 3,
y finalmente en color verde...
voy a poner raíz de...
raíz de 0.5 por 50 menos 1
0.5 por 50 es 25
la raíz de 5 menos 1 es igual a 4.
Excelente, entonces observa,
esto está padre,
pudimos haber tomado
una muestra arbitraria de valores de "x"
pero iba a quedar muy feo por las raíces cuadradas.
Pensando en que "0.5x" es un cuadrado
entonces ya todo quedó mucho más limpio, vale,
Bueno,
ahora sí, ya tenemos los puntos,
ya tenemos nuestra tabla,
los valores de "x" y los de "f" de "x",
déjame graficar la función.
Observa, todos estos valores de "x"
son mayores o iguales que 0
y no es casualidad,
de hecho...
de hecho, el dominio de la función "f" de "x",
son los números
que son mayores o iguales que 0,
y ¿a qué se debe esto?
¿por qué el dominio está restringido?
pues tiene que ver con esta raíz de acá,
con raíz de "0.5x",
para que un número tenga raíz cuadrada,
como lo hemos visto hasta ahorita,
ese número tiene que ser mayor o igual que 0,
ahorita no vamos a pensar en números imaginarios,
y si no los conoces ni te preocupes, vale,
el chiste es que necesitamos que "0.5x"
sea mayor o igual que 0,
"0.5x" sea mayor "x" 0.5
se me estaba escapando esa "x",
esto queremos que sea mayor o igual que 0
y por lo tanto,
"x" es mayor o igual que 0, vale,
entonces pues el dominio son las
"x" mayores o iguales que 0
y esto de aquí es una muestra.
Ahora sí vamos a graficar.
Este... ya dije mucho y no he dibujado nada.
Entonces vamos a poner por aquí...
ah claro, es que dije todo eso para justificar
que los ejes me iban a quedar así.
Déjame poner este un poco más arriba.
¿Va?
Entonces como el dominio son
las "x" mayores o iguales que 0,
le voy a dar más importancia
a este lado del eje "x",
acá voy a poner el eje "y" igual a "f" de "x"
y vamos a ver,
qué escala tendríamos que poner aquí y acá, vale.
A ver, "x" va de 0 a 50,
entonces sería bueno poner por acá más o menos 10,
por aquí 20,
por acá 30,
por acá 40
y por 50, vale,
entonces, estos son los valores en "x"
que podemos tomar.
Y ahora vamos a ver qué pasa con "y"
"y" va de -1 a 4.
Bueno, entonces déjame poner por aquí...
por aquí está bien, por aquí voy a poner el -1,
por acá el 1, por acá el 2,
el 3
y finalmente el 4.
Muy bien, entonces déjame pasar,
los valores de esta tabla aquí, a la gráfica,
entonces tomando este color como rojo...
tenemos que uno de los puntos es el 0, -1
que sería el 0,
en x, -1
entonces sería este de acá verdad, el 0, -1
ahora, hay que poner el 2, 0
Voy a poner el 2, 0
el 2 está bien cerquita de aquí
sí, está como a la quinta parte de
entre 0 y 10, entonces está como por acá,
¿va?
entonces este de acá es el punto 2, 0
Bueno está un poco chiquito pero es el 2, 0
Ok vamos con el tercer punto en color morado...
este de aquí es el 8, 1
el 8, 1
el 8 queda como por acá,
aquí está el 1,
este es el 1 en "y"
entonces este de aquí es el 8, 1
sigamos con este color azul...
al color azul le corresponde el
18, 2,
18, 2
más o menos por ahí,
luego sigue...
le voy a poner el 18, 2
luego sigue el 32, 3
voy a agarrar este color azul...
que es un poco más claro que el anterior...
32 está como por acá,
con matrices como por aquí,
vale, este es el 32, 3
y finalmente tenemos el punto 50, 4
50, 4
muy bien,
entonces 50, 4
que queda como por acá.
Muy bien entonces los puntos como que cada vez
se alejan más rápidamente del eje "y".
Ok,
ya tenemos estos puntos,
son algunos puntos en la gráfica,
ahora sí, para trazar la gráfica,
lo que tenemos que hacer
es conectar estos puntos, vale,
entonces déjame tomar el color blanco...
y más o menos,
la gráfica nos quedaría algo así.
¿Va?
Entonces aquí viene una línea blanca,
que pasa por este punto rosa,
luego pasa por el morado,
se empieza a acostar un poco más,
para pasar por éste, por el azulito,
y luego pasa por este que es color cian...
bueno azul claro,
azul claro, más o menos por ahí,
y finalmente se hace todavía más horizontal,
hasta que pasa por éste...
¡chin!
bueno, ahí me falló tantito el pulso pero
tiene que pasar por ahí vale.
Pasa por todos esos cinco puntos,
seis puntos...
Ah, es que a éste no le puse coordenadas,
este es el 50, 4
entonces pasa por esos seis puntos,
y ahora sí,
esta línea blanca, ya tiene todos los puntos
de la gráfica de la función
y si te das cuenta
se parece algo así como una...
como a una parábola acostada
y justo es eso,
justo es una parábola girada, vale.
Bueno,
entonces ya tenemos la gráfica de la función
y esta gráfica muestra todos los puntos
del estilo "x", "f" de "x"
para la función
"f" de "x" igual a raíz de "0.5x" menos 1